こんばんは！はじめしゃちょーと
こんばんは！あっちそっちy...
東京のとある心霊スポット付近
に来ております。
東京都の結構海の方の
若洲海浜公園というところに
きております。
とりあえず俺は今のうちにちょっと
周りの状況確認をしてくる。
イヤすぐかえってくるから！大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫、わかった
はい、こんな感じです。もう
真っ暗な森みたいになってます
結構昼間とかにぎわってるらしいんですけども
夜はもうこんな感じで
真っ暗らしいですっ
グッ
えーと...
若洲！
若洲海浜公園！
コーーーーーーーーーーーーーーン
ああぁ～
いやぁｗｗサバイバル
あれ？下調べしようよ
この公園に何という霊というか
どんな噂があるかちょっと調べてみましょう。
こっち向きもありだよ
うわっ怖　ヤバいヤバい、うわヤバいヤバいヤバっ
怖い怖い怖い
ねえヤバいよこれはヤバい
うわっ！うぉっ！！やばいやばいやばい　まじでまじでまじで！！
なに？？　なに？？？
うわぁ～、やべぇ
怖かったなぁ
何ですか、今の
この心霊スポットにはどのような噂があるかちょっと見てみましょう
早く早く、ちょっ早く
早く早くして
ちょっ早くして帰ろう
あっ、OKです。
え～っと、ちょっと場所を移動してきて
本当に心霊スポットの公園の近くまで来ました
え～っと、かなりヤンキーが多い
バイクがとりあえず多いですね
さっき普通にカーチェイスしててさ
パトカーと車が普通に競争しててマジでビビりました
こちらでございます
女子高生、コンクリートつめ殺人事件
ちょっと緊張感もってください
マジで言ってんの？
ガチかこれ
いやぁ～すげぇ、サイトがもう怖いですよね
治安が悪そうっすもんね、ここら辺
そう、やっぱ
そういうさ、なんかさ霊的な
もの集めるんじゃないかって思ってさ
なんか人を…ちょっと
悪い部分をだすようなスポットとして
えっとね、何だったけな
すごい昔、首を切られたらしくて
ここで人が
そういう霊的なやつも怖いってことを言ってた
あっ。やっぱりこの公園の近くで感じてるひと多い人って
うわぁ
という訳で、いろんな噂がある心霊スポットになっております
実際にちょっと色々まわって見ましょう
そうですね
奥の方ちょっと行って見ましょう
はい
マジ、やべぇあれ
いや～ボヤけるがひどいな、これ
なんで？
なんかボヤけるんすよ
何がおきてるの？
あっ、合いました今
うわ、めっちゃでけぇクモだ
スポット行く前に死にますよ
うわでもなんか、すっごい嫌な気がする
なんか嫌な雰囲気っていうのがありますね
ちょっと木とかヤバくないですか？
ほんとだ、うわぁ。誰が、誰渡る。この橋
ふさがれてるよ
今、あっ。ほら
鐘の音
あっ、虫
虫異常に多くね？
あー、もう
ヤバいヤバい
虫ヤバいっすね
最後、海の奥までいって終わろう
はいというわけでね、結構ね海の近くまで来ました
カメラで分かるかな？
おー！バシャーモ
バシャーモ俺のネタ
あっゴメン
危ない感じとは違うんだよな
きれいな公園なんですよ、たぶん昼間は
あ～確かに
夜の独特な雰囲気がすごい恐怖感を煽ってきます
ほら、手形多いよ
何してんのかな、これ
腹いてぇ
見ろ見ろ見ろ
ヤバいぞ
見ろ
水を飲んでる？
飲んでるこれは
おかしいおかしいおかしい
ちょっと待って
ほんとうに
もうやめて～、マジで
大丈夫ですか？